Jonathan restera mon fils quels sont vos
rapports avec lui aujourd'hui
ben ça va très bien on a retrouvé un peu
pour se parler puis notre complicité
vous le voyez régulièrement oui on va
régulièrement tous les 15 jours
pour vous
impression vous dites que Jonathan c'est
c'est quelqu'un de bien ça reste votre
fils mon fils c'était quelqu'un de bien
avant il a fait
voilà et il redevient quelqu'un de bien
bon il est enfermé il est en prison mais
il reste toujours quelqu'un de bien rien
ne dit que il pourrait refaire ça un
jour
comprenez que ça puis choquer d'entendre
ça
moi je parle avec le cœur d'une maman
donc moi je trouve pas choquant moi
un fils les enfants restent des enfants
on peut pas parce qu'il est passé
meurtrier qu'il faut plus aimer son
enfant on peut pas le laisser tomber non
plus il faut être présent
moi j'ai besoin de lui comme lui il a
besoin de moi
qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit les parents
d'Alexia après ils ont pas parlé vous
étiez proches de bon on était proche on
se voyait oui sans plus les relations
étaient cordiales et depuis
[Musique]
depuis près de 5 ans maintenant Jonathan
Daval est derrière les barreaux comme on
vous le trouvez comment il est mieux
il a bien récupéré
dans sa tête il paraît mieux si vous
permettez parce que l'écrit très bien et
que c'est difficile de s'exprimer sur un
plateau et comme dit Martine dans ses
yeux il y a quelque chose qui a changé
c'est ce que c'est ce que Martine
de toute façon pour avoir revu chaque
fois que j'ai revu de Jonathan Daval moi
je suis pas son je suis pas son père je
suis pas son ami je suis son avocat mais
je j'ai l'habitude
ses yeux et dans ses yeux on voit que
c'est quelqu'un qui porte le poids de ce
qu'il a fait on voit que c'est quelqu'un
qui vit constamment avec
l'idée le remord et le regret de ce
qu'il a fait ça c'est quelque chose qui
se ressent profondément Martine enfin
plana aussi l'explique très bien dans le
lit ça a changé irrémédiablement voilà
il n'a plus jamais été heureux alors
bien sûr que tout le monde va dire c'est
normal
oui c'est pas ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est quelle est la place
d'une maman par rapport à son fils quand
son fils a fait le pire justement ce que
c'est d'expliquer Martine comme vous
dites Cyril ça peut choquer bien sûr ça
peut choquer mais est-ce que ce serait
pas plus choquant d'une maman qui
abandonnerait son fils en disant et bien
puisque tu es devenu un meurtrier tu
n'es plus de notre famille on ne te
parlera plus on ne viendra plus te voir
on va nous aussi te juger une deuxième
fois alors que la société l'a déjà fait
la société t'a condamné t'as mis en
prison ben nous notre place c'est de
dire que malgré tout on t'aime malgré le
pire et on reste près de toi sans
excuser une seule seconde c'est aussi le
livre de Martine sans excuser une seule
seconde je n'ai jamais entendu Martine
avoir la moindre complaisance envers
dans le geste les gestes criminels
qu'avaient commis Jonathan il faut bien
comprendre ça ça peut paraître compliqué
à appréhender mais en réalité sa place
est terriblement compliquée Martine
c'est un navire parlé avec Jonathan
non jamais non une fois qu'il est qu'il
a été incarcé
comment vous le vivez aujourd'hui parce
que vous savez qu'il va y rester très
très très longtemps
mais on vit au jour le jour notre vie a
complètement changé
et on vit au jour le jour où on se lance
plus dans des projets
on fait plus rien alors il y a une
information qui a été donnée par le
journaliste dominicrisé il a quelques
jours
regardez tout le monde en a parlé vous
avez donné votre avis là-dessus ce qui
est sur ce qu'il est bien
dans sa maison centrale est en couple
avec un homme il a rencontré là-bas un
garçon un peu plus âgé que lui avec
lequel il vit une histoire histoire de
prisonniers c'est vrai que c'est ta
formation évidemment c'est sa vie privée
mais elle apporte un éclairage à cette
affaire différents tout le monde a
cherché à comprendre il avait des
troupes de l'érection prenez des
médicaments elle lui avait envoyé un
jour un SMS en lui disant enfin elle
parlait à une de ses amis elle avait
envoyé un sms Alexandre de ses amis en
lui disant je crois que même si je me
mène nu devant lui il ne se passe rien
il me regarde même pas
alors vous avez des mentir cette
information
qu'est-ce que vous avez quand vous avez
vu ça vous êtes dit quoi j'ai dit non
mais ça va pas la tête
j'en ai parlée
disait que il était en couple avec un
garçon puis j'ai dit à Jonathan si c'est
vrai tu me le dis ça changera rien on
t'aimera toujours
pour nous ça changera rien il m'a assuré
que non c'était pas vrai et puis comme
j'ai dit qu'il soit en couple avec un
garçon ou une fille ça ne regarde pas la
France c'est sa vie privée à lui de ce
qu'il a dit
monsieur m'a appelé il m'a fait des
excuses